you got back at your mom recently
because I'm told your mom played a prank
on you a long time ago she did and it
was it was pretty much it was a big
prank and you decided to get back at her
is that right yes I told the story of
what your mom did to you first
sure so I was around 12 and she decided
that it was like it's time I'm gonna
leave you at home alone for the first
time like it was like a rice
rite-of-passage thing it was like I'm
only gonna go out for an hour in the
middle of the day on a Sunday but you're
gonna stay home alone and you know and
this is like opening the door for
growing up great so because I'm a child
and apparently to that point in my life
had never really experienced fear I was
like I gotta get in the shower I gotta
take a shower and a home alone and so I
take the shower and then I get out and
you only like 5 10 minutes has passed
and I know she's gotten into the car and
left and I think I can hear her in the
apartment so I'm like mom
there's no response mom nothing and
again because I'm impossibly brave at
this point in my life I opened the door
mom step out as she jumps out and grabs
what and I literally scream cried and
peed I'm sorry what this plant here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna make her
think that it's a rite of passage I'm
gonna leave for five minutes in the car
and then scare the crap out of her
I don't know anyway so that was like 20
years ago I've never gotten her back and
is it haunted you since I literally
can't shower with the door closed so if
there's if there's somebody else in the
house then it's fine like I can close
the door but if I'm home alone or I'm at
a hotel or whatever the door has to stay
open and I literally have to like I
don't close my eyes in the shower like I
watch out the door like to this day
which I never realized until recently I
was like that's a direct reflection it's
drama yeah I said if your mom was having
fun or is she trying to teach you a
lesson like you never know who's in the
house which isn't even a lesson that's
just wrong yeah yeah exactly I'm real
mad at your mom I well so is I for
decades
all right so would you do so this week's
episode of super store which I wrote by
the way
my character is pregnant on the show and
there's an ultrasound at the top of the
episode so we had to have a really good
prosthetic belly and I was like in my
trailer and I caught a glimpse of myself
in the mirror and I was like this is it
this is it 20 years later so I took some
selfies where I'm looking very kind of
sullen in the picture and I keep looking
very very pregnant and it's a bare belly
like it's a really authentic belly and I
text them to my mom and I'm like listen
the reason Dina is pregnant on the show
is because I've kept a secret from you
I'm I'm very pregnant with my
ex-boyfriends baby oh my god and I
didn't know how to tell you so here you
go and I hit Send and then like
immediately I'm getting all caps text
back but what are you talking about you
have to call me you can't text that and
then my phone's ringing and I'm like
send a voicemail she's like and I was
like just like I'm not like this at all
but I was just like get drunk with power
I was like I just let her sit in it for
a good like five minutes and then I had
Ben Feldman on the show film me call her
on speakerphone to reveal to her that it
was actually just a prank and I was not
actually pregnant okay we have that
moment I think here I think this is you
finally letting your mom off the hook
yeah you're a pair of monsters let's
take a look it's true well I just I
didn't know how to tell you and I know
it seems like such a dramatic time and
everything that I felt like this is
probably the way that that I should tell
you
it's a prank mom it's a prank it's a
prank this this is pig this is payback
for when you scared me when I was 12 and
I peed
[Applause]
I absolutely love that okay that's fair
in that moment of her soul being
destroyed and then slowly reassembled
like assessing yeah yeah oh my god you
are horrible people but it felt great
yeah
so you wrote this this week's episode
yeah congratulations you're writing a
lot of episodes no this was the first
one and I kind of like asked to do it on
a lark like I you know I have writing
experience from back in Canada but I
hadn't written anything for TV in
America and I was like hey I'd be
interested and they were like all right
yeah I'm really proud of you superstore
airs Thursdays at 8:00 on NBC Laura Nash
I'm so happy that you're I'm so happy
that you're with a good guy I really am
- I mean I just I couldn't take it
anymore these horrifying stories no you
want to meet this guy someday I'll bring
them all right not right away
you